lis ça y est tous qui tue loup tac est
une passionnée de la mode elle a grandi
dans l'arctique canadien et rêve de
pouvoir un jour amené les design
traditionnel inuit sur les passerelles
de l'europe intéresse coaching grosse
moustache rousse
en septembre dernier elle s'est inscrite
au programme de design de fourrure
duarte échos orange dans sa ville natale
10 cas 8 afin d'apprendre le design de
mode pendant des milliers d'années ses
ancêtres ont utilisé la fourrure des
animaux et en particulier celle des
phoques pour se vêtir
mais le rêve de l'issat de gagner sa vie
grâce à la couture iodé zain est mise en
péril par une guerre de relations
publiques qui se déroule à des milliers
de kilomètres de là
le succès de cette campagne contre la
chasse aux phoques à galvaniser
l'opinion publique et entraîné une union
européenne a imposé un embargo sur tous
les produits dérivés du phoque
en théorie les inuits du groenland et du
canada qui dépendent toujours des
phoques pour assurer leur survie sont
exemptés de cet embargo
lequel est entré en vigueur à l'été 2010
c'est au soir des morts et blessés et
par la chasse aux phoques de subsistance
est bien différent de la chasse
commerciale que pourfendre les
défenseurs des droits des animaux
durant l'hiver les phoques vivent sous
la glace mais il remonte à la surface
pour respirer à travers les trous dans
les fissures créé par le mouvement des
plaques de glace de la banquise
les chasseurs inuits parcours des
douzaines de kilomètres à la recherche
de citron
ensuite ils doivent attendre sans bouger
dans le froid mordant attendre dit
attendre et attendre encore dans cette
loterie gouverné par dame nature
même si un phoque remonte finalement la
surface rien ne garantit que le chasseur
obtiendra sa 3 au printemps lorsque les
phoques se déplace sur la banquise les
chasseurs doivent s'en approcher le plus
possible
un seul coup de feu bien visible suffit
généralement pour tuer l'animal sans lui
causer trop de souffrance les et nuit
doivent payer 3 4 fois plus cher pour
acheter des aliments que dans le sud
la viande de phoque leur permet donc de
compléter leur alimentation
les chasseurs partage habituellement
leurs prises avec leur père
ceux qui sont ou bien trop pauvres ou
bien physiquement incapable d'aller
chasser eux mêmes avant l'introduction
de l'embargo les inuits pouvait aussi
compter sur la vente des peaux de phoque
pour arrondir leurs maigres revenus
à présent cela ne vaut même plus la
peine de prendre le temps de retirer le
gras les peaux de phoques sont la
plupart du temps je t'ai quand elles ne
deviennent pas de la nourriture pour les
chiens et les corneilles l'embargo
infligé un dur coup à une population
déjà très appauvri au cours des deux
dernières générations les inuits ont dû
composer avec des changements
considérables dans leur mode de vie
très souvent on les a obligés à quitter
leur campement de nomades pour aller
vivre dans des communautés qui offre
tous les pièges de la vie moderne mais
bien peu de ces avantages
et depuis peu ils doivent aussi
s'ajuster aux conséquences des
changements climatiques
l'embargo décrété par l'union européenne
taralis déjà presque complètement le
marché des peaux de phoque l'an dernier
à l'encan des fourrures de north bay en
ontario
pas la moindre pot n'a été vendu par
milliers 11500 qui avaient été chassés
par les inuits du nunavut
et c'est ce qui a amené la sénatrice
canadienne céline hervieux payette de la
province de québec à faire pression sur
le gouvernement fédéral pour qu'il
compense les pêcheurs de l'atlantique et
les chasseurs du nunavut de doux de
citou l'embargo européen a déclenché la
colère de beaucoup de gens ou nunavut
e
maybelline
oui après celle du specta en plus des
jeunes giroud est venu dans l'arctique
avec l'idée de transférer aux jeunes
femmes inuites ses connaissances en
design de mode ni en couture afin de les
aider à se sortir de la pauvreté et
nexity fille côte feuillée inuits et
mixité fico for as to developing to
accept that might have a great thou mais
les autorités du nunavut craignent que
cet embargo contre les produits du
phoque ne soit le début d'une guerre des
cultures qui opposerait les citadins
occidentaux aux pêcheurs de la côte est
you chasseur inuit
ce qui m'agace c'est que tout est dit
c'est le paradoxe est minime au public a
requis mardi soir femmes les deux
narines et adam quand le gouvernement
fédéral du canada conteste cet embargo
auprès de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
en attendant le gouvernement du nunavut
cherche une solution à long terme baa2
lissa issue lutins que croit que les
défenseurs des droits des animaux ainsi
que les députés européens devraient se
familiariser avec la réalité de la vie
dans l'arctique continue de s'accrocher
à son rêve de gosse
tropico 3